it's an adrenaline rush that just from anxiety and
nervousness seems like it's always the
first game 5-a-side football for me is the
fuel I found to keep
fighting
my name is andré de souza carlos is 40
years old
my vision problem came from
childhood
I  I had an accident and the vision got
weaker each time one day the green
she totally
doesn't play 5
diana football almost four years it's played people
with four players na li in goalkeeper
we have to use blindfolds to take
advantage of any player who has resided
division
the ball has a bell for us to
orient ourselves by this sound
after i went blind i
lost the will to go to a
barbecue i
touched my instrument and i fell down
there at the bottom of the well it was also a
16 months of mourning and  thinking about giving up
on giving up life and that is bad was really
bad even after I started playing
football and
other feelings only grew back to
joy disposition the desire for an armadillo
people who return society to work their
minds returned to work with other
expectations other dreams hotels new
goals I gained conquest everything
through football